i'm emily compagno i'm guy benson i'm
shannon breme and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday june 9th 2021 i'm lisa brady
for decades now crack cocaine has been
treated differently under federal law
than the powder version
could changing that help answer calls
for racial justice
it is time to pass the legislation that
would eliminate that disparity
and i do believe that would increase
trust and confidence and
fairness in our system we speak with
arkansas governor asa hutchinson
i'm dave anthony with so many people
vaccinated
kovid is on the decline but not
everywhere
there's been a spike in some rural parts
of america
more cases than ever honestly it has
been
it's been a perfect storm of things but
unfortunately
i think a perfect storm that could
happen anywhere
and i'm jimmy fella i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
you may have noticed a pattern in the
national headlines lately
crime on the rise not only shootings but
hate crimes and other attacks
often raised by critics of defunding the
police as a reason to
increase funding and manpower instead
cities have responded in a variety of
ways
this is the first time in this country
that the atf has partnered
with a local police department in this
manner new york city mayor bill de
blasio announcing tuesday
that agents from the federal bureau of
alcohol tobacco and firearms will be
embedded with nypd officers
to help reduce crime by finding illegal
guns and getting them off the streets
new police crime stats show shootings up
more than 68 percent in new york city
compared to the same time last year in
minneapolis where the death of george
floyd fueled
mass protests for racial justice and
where a now former officer has been
convicted of murder
some residents are suing the city and
the mayor accusing them of failing to
keep residents safe
and arguing in part that a city council
move to decrease police funding
has led to resignations contributing to
escalating crime
but in general debates about policing
reform and criminal justice reform
aren't really new and there's a renewed
push right now to address a
long-standing disparity
the difference between powder cocaine
and crack cocaine under federal law
which critics say has helped fuel
distrust in law enforcement
especially in black communities for
decades
when it comes to crime you have to look
at every area
in which crime is a problem arkansas's
republican governor asa hutchinson is
also a former congressman and was head
of the drug enforcement administration
under president george w bush you know
here
in arkansas we've had some level of
increase in crime but we've seen it go
down over the last decade we've seen it
start creeping up again
and so there's a lot of combinations in
that
i don't think you can point to
uh the fact that we're not
arresting the right people i think the
fact is
that we are arresting people we're
prosecuting people
but we need to make sure that we have
the long enough sentences for the
violent criminals
and some of those come out and they
recycle into the
life of crime we've got to concentrate
more in terms of our reentry system
so that we can have better supervision
better parole
supervision and and re-entry work to
help them get a job
but ultimately if they're just going to
cycle in and out in terms of violent
crime we need to keep them longer
uh but uh you know we've got to have
tough prosecution we've got to arrest
the right people
and then we've got to have a effective
re-entry programs
there is a problem and many in law
enforcement
have acknowledged it as well an issue
with communities especially black
communities
trusting law enforcement and the
criminal justice system
what can be done to repair and
strengthen those
community relationships or is that even
possible well that's one of the reasons
that i support
uh eliminating the disparity and
sentencing between crack cocaine and
powder cocaine
and i do believe that is a factor one
factor
uh and that is a lack of trust of the
system
but you know it goes much beyond that
and whenever you have a crack cocaine
that is sentenced
18 times more in length than
powder cocaine and when you look at the
fact that
the african-american population
constitutes 81 percent of all crack
convictions that means
uh the african-american community is
getting uh
prison sentences that are 18 times
longer simply because of that disparity
now what does that mean on the street it
means that
there's a lack of confidence and equal
treatment under the law
which is foundational to
the criminal justice system so i do
believe it's a factor
and that is one of the reasons that
i support uh eliminating that disparity
which i've actually worked on for more
than 20 years
since i was in congress and head of the
dea and we've made progress on it but
it is time to pass the legislation that
would eliminate that disparity
and i do believe that would increase
trust and confidence and fairness in our
system
i know that gap between the way powder
cocaine and crack cocaine
are treated in federal law i know that
gap has been narrowed over the years
when that disparity was first created
was it intended
to target people of color and poorer
communities or did it just end up doing
that well i think it just
ended up doing that at the time which
was
in the 1980s we had an epidemic of crack
cocaine
across the country and many times it was
associated with
violence and and so congress uh
naturally stiffened the penalties on
crack cocaine
part of the belief was that there was
something in the chemical
properties of crack cocaine or its
association
with violence that it ought to have
greater
penalties than a powder cocaine but over
the years
i think we law enforcement has
recognized that that disparity is not
based upon a good foundation and that
it ought to be eliminated that's the
reason
they did eliminate or reduce that
disparity from 100 to one down to 18 to
one which is tremendous progress
that was a bipartisan bill by senator
jeff sessions and senator dick
durbin and so that was a success story
that was progress
but i do believe you can say that it's
it's more importantly to completely
eliminate that disparity
but no i don't think it was started out
on a
racial basis but the impact
is disparate in terms of its racial
treatment and so you have to worry about
that
that's that's the outcome of it is that
we have more african americans spending
longer time
uh in prison uh than uh those that use
powder cocaine and
and uh that's a racial disparity that
is not good for our system and creates
distrust
when it comes to law enforcement
governor are you hoping for action in
congress
on police reform or would you rather
they leave as much change as possible up
to the states
well we have enacted uh some reform
measures here in arkansas
that increases the training for our law
enforcement
it also makes sure that
we have a database of those that are
fired because of excessive
excessive action that's not authorized
and so we've taken some reform measures
here
i do believe that there can be some
national steps that are taken
but you've got to be careful not to
undermine
the authority of police the funding
of police you've got to stand behind
them because
they're the ones that keeps us safe i
know that senator tim scott
of south carolina is working hard on
reform legislation and this is something
our party should be able to agree upon
but i hope that they'll continue to work
on it
but present it in a way that increases
training and accountability
but does not undermine destroy the
confidence that we
need to have in our law enforcement
officers
there's another issue that's kind of
been in a tug of war lately between
congress and states
and that's voting rights and even
without any evidence of widespread
fraud there are many republicans who
feel tightening
voting rules is a matter of election
security
and integrity so i'm wondering if you
think that changes made in georgia and
texas for being
unfairly targeted and branded as
restricting the right to vote
i do think they're being unfairly
targeted you know the sound bites about
not allowing water you know for those
waiting in line
i think those are just catch phrases and
the fact is that they're trying to
protect
the integrity of the ballot and we've
got to be able to change the
rhetoric and the debate where it's not
security versus access
we've got to increase access and
increase security at the same time
and that's my objective is that you know
voter integrity is the right
approach but at the same time
you know in arkansas we've increased our
early voting
and the access to that as well absentee
voting is is
fine a longer period of time to vote is
fine as long as it's accompanied by
the integrity measures and so you can
accomplish both and that's what
our focus should be i know that you've
known
both victory and defeat at the polls
over
several decades now are you concerned at
all about the where the republican party
stands right now and what would your
message
be for the party heading into the
midterms
my message would be let's focus on
the biden harris administration where we
believe it is going the wrong direction
uh define the differences in terms of
policy and substance and not
by personal attacks and we cannot win in
by making the race about uh
one person or one personality if we lose
under those circumstances and we have to
have
uh the party that's based upon principle
to win
and those are the simple principles of a
restrained government individual
responsibility
strong national defense these are things
that are
historic principles of the republican
party that's what we've got to get back
to
and when we do that we win it cannot be
about a division it can't be about
one personality it's got to be about
what we really believe and the
differences with this administration
arkansas governor asa hutchinson thank
you very much sir for your time we
appreciate it
it's great to be with you thank you
this is jimmy fella with your fox news
commentary coming up
the pandemic isn't over but covet is on
the decline
averaging under 15 000 cases a day
across america the past week
yet another decrease of nearly 30
percent from the prior seven day average
and cdc director dr
rochelle walensky says there's been a
decrease of 83 percent
in hospitalization since january 9th of
this year
and vaccinations are a big reason more
than 300 million
shots in arms so far but in some parts
of the country where
more people are wary of the vaccines
covid's not
it's spiking honestly it has been
it's been a perfect storm of things but
unfortunately
i think a perfect storm that could
happen anywhere dr
kendall gino is medical director for the
lynn county health department
in missouri where they had their worst
coveted surge yet
in may lynn in a neighboring county
topped the new york times tracker for
most cases per capita in the country
in mid-may we experienced
a spike in the number of people that
were experiencing coveted symptoms
and who then subsequently tested
positive
and since that time cases have been
going up until fortunately recently it
looks like things are
maybe leveling out but we had active
cases that were higher than
any that we had ever experienced in the
pandemic
this hit all around the same time as
graduation
was happening and graduation parties and
then
to top it all off we also found out
that we actually did and and do
have the the delta variant uh of
the cova 19 of the coronavirus that's uh
had been known as the indian variant but
uh now it's known as a delta variant
which is more infectious
and so all of those things combined plus
our vaccination rate in
lynn county especially and in livingston
as well
especially in the age group under 50 is
pretty
pretty abysmal it's pretty low a lot of
a lot of folks who are elderly and a lot
of the long-term care facility residents
got vaccinated but
but a lot of folks a lot of vaccine
hesitancy in
individuals under 50 and i think that
all combined
to cause the spike that we're currently
seeing
all right there's a lot to go through
there let's begin with how
this came up in the middle of may
you guys had to be surprised right i
mean
april were you seeing any cases anymore
was it was coveted
was gone pretty much right yeah pretty
much yep there were several weeks
several weeks uh maybe even a month with
absolutely zero cases
and suddenly it comes out of nowhere
yep yep in in one week we had
21 active cases um and then from there
um by the next week we had 85 and then
we topped out at 200
204 which is about one active case for
every 60 people
uh in linn county all right because
you're a pretty rural area right you
don't have a lot of residents
so you about 12 000 you say so that's
what
one out of 60. so if you do the math on
that
that means that would be the same if if
this was america and not just linn
county
that would be five and a half million
active cases
which is really something considering
we've only had
i shouldn't say only but we've had 33
million the entire pandemic so
this is a large number for you guys and
obviously you were surprised so what did
you do about it
sure so you know we we
very much made the um a lot of the then
the same recommendations we had been
making all along which
unfortunately are you know as far as
masking like not gathering in large
groups
making sure that people are isolated and
quarantining appropriately
but i'll tell you it's a really hard
sell when
every time people turn on the radio or
the tv it's like oh you know kova's
improving
like well but wait not here and then you
have the cdc guidance also in may
that was like look you don't even have
to wear masks anymore outside and all
that kind of stuff so
your counter you are countering a very
difficult message to defeat
absolutely and and and not that that was
in context
in the country not that that was wrong
advice it's just whenever your case
counts are as high as they were in linn
county
we had to have other guidance you know
we just said look you
even if you're vaccinated you should
wear a mask right now because
the cases are just that high at this
point and we were seeing lots of
lots of what appeared to be reinfections
people that were
that tested positive for covid back in
september october and were sick
improved did great you know no problem
and then became ill again
this you know in may um and again tested
positive
now is that do you know why that is i
mean i know there were a lot of people
talking last year
people who were like uh who wanted to
just have these covert parties get it
over with get your call get get infected
and then you'd be immune forever people
were thinking is this that covid was
still in their body
or they actually got a new infection and
therein is the
that's a fantastic question and we don't
have the capability
as rural tiny rural health departments
to be able to tell you that because
what it comes down to is that what you
have to do is to prove reinfection you
really kind of have to
you have to test them and figure out
what kind of covid they had the first
time
so you have to actually type it the
first time they get infected and then
you have to type it the second time too
and then and no one we're not doing that
of course no no one really is and so
yeah it only it looks like there that
we're seeing re infections
thankfully no one has died as of yet
from this particular from this
particular wave
we have had roughly about the same
amount of hospitalizations though
as as previous and some icu stays as
well
i think the biggest difference though is
that we have seen
that really in our little you know tiny
population the the vaccination is
working
because we're not seeing any so far
nursing home cases like we had in
november and december because those
populations
are really vaccinated and so even though
we've had employees
accidentally expose residents
who we we haven't seen that infection
then take hold and of course
just like in most of the country that's
back in november december that's where
we saw
many of the deaths coming from were from
our long-term care facilities
okay so these people who were infected
in may and maybe in early june they're
all
unvaccinated and so
or most is that better to say the
vast majority i i don't know there may
have
again for patient privacy and all of
that um i believe
we have had at least a case of
of a vaccinated individual that did uh
that did
then test positive for covet but most
the vast
vast majority are unpacked dr gino said
vaccination rates
were abysmal for those 50 and under well
here are the numbers as of monday in
lynn county missouri
about a third of the total population
has had at least
one covet vaccine dose nationwide that
number
is almost 52 percent and if most of the
elderly there
are vaccinated it shows how many younger
people in that county
don't want the shots though the recent
coveted surge has changed a few minds
to some degree we have seen uptick in
in vaccinations in the area i think when
there's a clear
and present danger then it's a little a
little easier to go ahead and make the
jump
um to get that vaccine um
as far as reasons oh goodness i mean
it really varies depending on depending
on the person that you talk to
you know some folks have what i would
nicely
say sound like somewhat fringe beliefs
about
some concern about oh you know even
microchips or you know things like that
being right
being implanted all the way to
less fringe ideas just of concerns of
uh reaction to the vaccine or that they
feel like it's
too new or things like that right it's
an unproven is an
unproven vaccine it was only emergency
authorized uh
and all of that um exactly what do you
do you try to sway them
or change their opinions i
i you know to be honest i kind of first
i read the person and my relationship
with them
right you know and and then i do my best
from there and
and we talk about how you know when i
got the vaccine
as a healthcare provider back in
december you know i can say that
okay maybe it was a little bit maybe it
was a little bit risky at that time
because only
you know fifty thousand sixty thousand
less than a hundred thousand people had
had it
and and only for a few months but now
now we've had millions of people who
have had it
and and it's been months and months and
months
you know and and so you know i just tell
them like for me
i'm i'm about as sure of this vaccine as
i can possibly
be about anything in medicine at this
point you know
but it's uh it does seem to work and and
with very very minimal side effects what
about kids
how how many of these infections were
were children
uh and did and how did it affect school
i know you talked about graduations
yep so it would have impacted school
a lot because we did see several in
um in some kiddos uh in school age
certainly in high school
uh aged kids we saw um
are part of this spike really though
school ended
right around the time that the spike
really hit
because school let out i think a week
after we saw that initial 20 case jump
all of a sudden so we we probably would
have been in a situation where we might
have even had to
just by simple fact of people being on
quarantine
and staff being unquarantined and all
that it
it would have negatively impacted our uh
the school but
again it was already let out for the
summer so at this point
you sound optimistic that you hope that
that wave
has uh crested and you're on the other
side and maybe
this whatever spike you had is ending
that's that's um i'm going to
tentatively
say that today because um numbers have
numbers have dropped a little bit on the
day-to-day but again
as we all know or as we've learned
through this whole thing as we've kind
of become
epidemiologists we have to look at that
seven day average
and certainly that's come down um and so
again
we're cautiously optimistic that we're
we're on the on the good end of this
my concern is for neighboring counties
right
and other places in missouri where the
vaccination rates are just as
uh or even in the entire midwest where
the vaccination rates are just as bad
um because all it takes is just
one person right to carry a variant into
your
in into your neck of the woods and then
you know could totally be in the same
situation we are
dr kendall gino medical director lynn
county health department in missouri
thanks for sharing your story we hope
that uh it it does peter out and get a
lot better
thanks so much yeah absolutely thank you
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast
former federal prosecutor and four-term
u.s congressman from south carolina
brings you a one-of-a-kind podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
subscribe to this podcast at
it's time for your fox news commentary
jimmy fallon
what's on your mind so president trump
told the north carolina crowd he's
leaning towards running again
and the crazy part is he could win if
all of his supporters get out of jail by
then
relax folks i've gotta make fun of both
sides because these days
the only time comedians hit both sides
is when they're kissing democrat butts
but as for trump running again
that didn't shock me half as much as
suggestions that joe biden was thinking
about running again in 2024.
folks biden didn't run in 2020. the dude
stayed home the whole campaign mumbled
his way through a couple of zoom
interviews when the teleprompter went
out most guys i know campaigned harder
to be president of their fantasy
football league than biden did to be
president but technically speaking joe's
in charge now and the only thing he's
doing a good job of is calling our
country racist
biden wrecked the border by repealing
trump's policies he crushed ten thousand
energy jobs by killing the keystone
pipeline and he totally caved to the
teachers unions despite
all the available science saying it was
safer for kids to be in the classroom
biden would be 82 in 2024 and while no
president has ever held office at such
an advanced age it's his policies
that'll make him
old news love fox news click the
subscribe button to get more of the news
and opinion you trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes